Ce samedi sur RADIO Bruno Fort.
Dans quelques jours se Xavier
le sommet pour un nouveau pacte
financier mondial. Comment
l'argent des pays du Nord peut
permettre la transition
climatique dans ceux du sud,
l'économiste Mario PSG Xavier
du centre de développement de
l'OCDE nous donne les clés de
cet événement international.
Éco d'ailleurs avec la BOAD.
Tous les samedis à dix heures
dix TU sur RFI.
Rfi
et France 24 présentent
Radio FOOT International, le
Café des sports, Annie Gasnier.
Bonjour, bonsoir à tous, merci
d'être au rendez-vous du café
des sports, merci de nous
rejoindre, de nous être fidèles
aussi hein, la la fin de saison
Xavier mais euh, il y aura
encore une tournée de café
aujourd'hui et les fidèles sont
là mais alors excusez-moi
messieurs mais je veux qu'on
salue le retour de celui qui
nous manque étant, qui
préférait la petite balle jaune
au ballon sur les pelouses
vertes. Bonjour Frédéric
bonjour Annie content, heureux
de vous retrouver, on est là,
on est là vous avez manqué euh,
aux auditeurs à chaque fois il
nous disait mais qui va être le
relais alors, j'ai essayé, j'ai
essayé pas si j'y suis arrivée
mais en tout cas j'ai essayé
grâce à aux stagiaires on
attend les messages c'est parti
euh, RADIO Xavier sont la
fidèle au rendez-vous bonjour
messieurs moi je suis toujours
fidèle au rendez-vous sauf que
l'autre peut être sur la
doublure et peut s'enfuir de
temps en temps donc c'est comme
ça bon et puis comme il a quand
même pris un renfort à côté de
lui par hasard parfois euh,
très Xavier lui aussi c'est un
fidèle du Café des sports
bonjour Benjamin bonjour à
tous. Merci beaucoup titulaire
ici hein. mais on aime bien de
temps en temps faire rentrer
des remplaçants alors voilà. On
partage. Dans les débats du
jour euh, il y a beaucoup
d'actualité aujourd'hui alors
on a essayé de de faire des
choix. Il y a d'abord cette
cinquième journée décisive dans
les Xavier pour la prochaine
CAN pour certains, cette
journée pourrait d'ailleurs
être déterminante. Par exemple
le Gabon peut se qualifier
alors que les léopards qui
seront leurs adversaires
seraient en très mauvaise
posture s'ils perdaient
beaucoup d'enjeux pour un seul
week-end. Une finale de ligue
des nations de prestige, la
Croatie jouera face à l'Espagne
pour remporter enfin un
trophée. Après ces récentes
déconvenues dans les grandes
compétition mais les jeunes de
la sont très ambitieux. Rituno
N Italia pour Rudi Garcia le
Napoli a choisi l'entraîneur
français pour diriger les
champions du scooter. Est-ce un
choix osé de la part du
président napolitain Nous
essayerons d'y répondre à cette
question. Kylian Mbappé ou le
feuilleton permanent , on ne
s'ennuie jamais avec le
capitaine de l'équipe de France
qu'il y ait ou non euh une
balle à ses pieds. Ce surdoué
n'en fait-il pas trop hors des
terrains? Question que nous
nous poserons donc enfin des
missions, David Finzel m'a aidé
à préparer l'émission avec euh
Pierre Guérin. Laurence est à
la réalisation et pour les
moyens vidéos, nous avons
Steven Esly et Yann Bourdela.
Le Café des sports, les débats
sont ouverts.
Une avant-dernière chance pour
rallier la Côte d'Ivoire en
janvier prochain. Voilà ce
coffre euh aux équipes
africaines, aux sélections qui
ne sont pas encore euh
évidemment qualifiée cette
cinquième journée
d'éliminatoire. Alors à ce
jour, huit équipes sont
qualifiées, il y a encore donc
du travail pour d'autres et on
a décidé de s'attacher à euh la
République Démocratique du
Congo, la RDC qui jouera à
Franceville contre le Gabon.
Euh alors les hommes de Patrice
Neveux, eux, les Gabonais, se
sont entraînés euh ces jours-ci
à Bongoville dans, ça ne
invente pas dans le rang euh de
nouveaux euh Pierre-Emerick euh
Aubameyang et Mario Le Mina
hein on vous en avait parlé ils
ont ils ont retrouvé la la
sélection des panthères. Une
victoire leur offrirait euh dès
demain la qualification mais
les léopards eux qui sont mal
partis euh dans ces
éliminatoires doivent se
ressaisir. Ils ont commencé par
un stage au Cameroun euh ces
derniers jours et surtout en
début euh d'émission pour euh
en début de hum euh de de stage
pour leur donner un peu
d'énergie, vous allez le voir
ou l'entendre, eh bien chancel
Memba a été fêté pour son titre
de meilleur joueur africain de
la ligue un.
Bouleau palais, palais,
bouleau, euh je pense que ça va
devenir le refrain euh euh pour
certains euh joueurs euh
africains et surtout sans doute
euh une Xavier quand même euh
Benjamin Moukandjo finalement,
on se concentre sur euh sur son
travail. Oui bien sûr, je pense
que beaucoup de gens disent que
le football c'est un
divertissement, mais oui,
au-delà du divertissement que
ça peut être, c'est-à-dire
c'est quand même un boulot
parce que on est quand même
payé pour le faire et puis euh
ben quand on va au boulot comme
euh tout chef d'entreprise ou
comme toute personne qui
travaille, ben on a
l'obligation du résultat. Non
mais c'est une jolie euh
expression euh dont nous avait
parlé chancel hein, de sa
détermination, de son travail
aussi lorsqu'on lui avait remis
donc le le trophée Marc Vivien
Foé. Les léopards ont été
repris euh en main par euh
Sébastien euh Desabres et ils
ont remporté euh leur troisième
victoire. C'était un match
amical, c'était justement au
Cameroun et c'était contre
l'Ouganda que Sébastien Dessabe
connaît bien, on se souvient
qu'il a aussi été
sélectionneur. Est-ce que c'est
un bon signe pour vous en tout
cas euh Benjamin de de de
partir à cet Xavier au moins
euh bon ben ce résultat est pas
tous les titulaires, on sait et
tout, mais en tout cas euh de
donner de l'élan. C'est surtout
de redonner un peu une certaine
dynamique que la RDC a depuis
un moment, c'est de gagner.
Parce qu'effectivement, ils
vont jouer un match décisif
contre le Gabon qui, je pense,
va probablement se qualifier
avec sept points, ils se sont
bien partis pour en tout cas.
Mais en face, bien sûr, ils ont
une forte équipe du Gabon. Le
Gabon, c'est une équipe,
aujourd'hui, il va falloir
aller les bouger. à domicile.
Et à domicile, et quand on voit
la RDC on s'étonne quand même
hein, parce que moi je
regardais encore l'émission, la
liste des joueurs qu'ils ont
quand même en RDC, on dit que
se retrouver
c'est c'est c'est c'est quand
même triste et on en parlait
plusieurs fois dans dans cette
émission du du problème quand
même quà la la RDC en terme de
de de football, même de
football local qui n'arrive pas
à se mettre en place. Donc je
pense que cette victoire va
forcément leur faire du bien
parce que bien sûr il faut
enclencher une nouvelle
dynamique positive et ben bien
sûr aller jouer parce que ça va
être pour moi c'est le
tournant. Si vous gagnez pas
contre cette équipe ben ça va
être ça va être plié pas encore
Xavier CAN je je pense un pays
comme le le la RDC avec les
joueurs que ça comporte, les
joueurs qui sont passés de
manquer de CAN c'est ça peut
être quand même difficile.
Alors qu'en même temps ils
avaient failli se ils auraient
pu se qualifier pour euh pour
la coupe du monde Ils étaient
dans les matchs de étaient en
barrage contre le Maroc,
c'était le d'ailleurs le seul
barrage pour la Coupe du monde
qui n'était pas qualifiée des
nations. Ouais. Donc euh ça
démontre qu'ils ont un vrai
potentiel mais l'exprime de
façon très Xavier beaucoup trop
Xavier pour un pays de 100
millions d'habitants c'est
ahurissant qui est pas le la
les pas les léopards du du
Congo à chaque Coupe d'Afrique
des nations, il devrait y être
à chaque édition et ils ont du
mal à se qualifier c'est
ahurissant euh c'est un immense
gâchis et on espère que
Sébastien Dessabe va arriver à
les à les remobiliser mais là
ça va être compliqué au Gabon,
derrière il y aura le match
contre le Soudan et ils avaient
perdu au Soudan en plus dans
dans ce match de foot. De toute
façon ils ont ils ont ils ont
ils ont gagné qu'une fois la
Mauritanie euh qui était qui a
fini à Nice. Donc euh pour le
moment c'est C'est très
compliqué pour la RDC alors
qu'il y a des joueurs euh
fabuleux. De classement
peut-être hein euh Gabon sept
points. Soudan six, Mauritanie
cinq, RDC quatre points.
Là il faudrait faire beaucoup
de points euh en seulement deux
matchs et c'est ça qui est
compliqué. Bon il y a une
histoire de recours contre euh
un joueur euh de Mauritanie et
tout mais comme rien n'est
décidé, rien, surtout on n'a
pas de verdict, donc on fait
comme si euh ce recours euh eh
bien euh on attendait toujours
le résultat et on se sur le
sportif, RADIO parlez-nous des
léopards parce que on l'a
évoqué l'autre jour à travers
Chancel Memba hein, et lui il
disait je veux recrédibiliser
aussi le football congolais
euh, je je suis un peu la tête
de pont et c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être ça qui leur manque de
d'être assez concentré? Manque
de concentration et aussi la
dégradation du niveau technique
de certains éléments clés tels
que sans championnat hein en
plus euh, pour ce qui est de de
de parce que on avait quand
même des cadres. Comme Kalulu.
Ouais. Euh peut-être que
titularisé qui aurait pu
peut-être mieux jouer. Mais il
y a une lueur d'espoir. Bien
sûr. C'est que toujours.
Effectivement avec euh celui
qui a été élu par RADIO
comme meilleur joueur africain
de RADIO de évoluer en France.
On retrouve une équipe des
léopards qui n'est pas
uniquement offensive. C'est une
équipe qui dans les deux
derniers matchs n'a pas pris de
but. Grâce à qui? Non seulement
Bemba, mais il a aussi Babou
Tiki quelque chose comme ça en
tout cas j'ai vu un bon
défenseur central qui allait au
duel. Vous avez aussi un
gardien de but où j'avais
beaucoup de doutes. Baggio. Il
n'a pas pris de but. Ça veut
dire que ils vont avec une
certaine confiance face au
Gabon Moi je crois plutôt que
les Lyon parlent du euh de la
RDC risquent de piéger le Gabon
à domicile parce que le Gabon
lui a fait beaucoup de bruit
avec le retour des pierres
Xavier Aubameyang, qui faut-il
le dire en Angleterre? Sur les
15 derniers matchs il n'a
marqué qu'un but.
Saint-Pierre-Émilie
33 buts alors À 33 ans. Alors 7
ans qui avait 30 buts dans les
sélections Les Gabonais sont
convaincus qu'aujourd'hui il
peut encore être l'atout
principal de leur Xavier or je
dis bien que surtout le
président du Gabon non qui est
convaincu. Pardon? C'est le
président du Gabon qui l'a fait
revenir. On va pas dire le
président parce que il a eu un
entretien avec le président du
Gabon le 8 le 8 mai Xavier avec
le père le père également de
ils ont eu un rôle dans la
sélection tous les présidents
c'est-à-dire c'est là où il y a
un un problème. Paul Biya fait
ce coup là avec Roger Milla a
fait ça avec euh peut-être bon
on peut dire Patrick Mbappé
mais honnêtement quand on voit
maintenant que oh Ali Bongo
veut faire ce coup-là avec le
Gabon alors là il va faire très
attention si le Gabon qui
faut-il dire, sans
Pierre-Emerick Aubameyon. Mais
oui. Sans les mineurs avaient
réussi à aller en huitième de
finale, aller en quart de
finale
exacte
ment. C'est d'ailleurs
l'inconnu finalement de de
cette rencontre. Voilà.
Frédéric? Non mais il y a
beaucoup d'espoir et beaucoup
de messages là qui arrivent sur
la page Facebook, du côté des
des Congolais, mais on sent la
fébrilité euh Douglas euh
Kaluende, la RDC n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur euh Michael
Michael lui reprend euh
l'exemple de la NBA, il dit
c'est un match euh d' Xavier
Game hein euh vaincre ou
mourir, il y a plus le choix.
La RDC traverse une mauvaise
période on le sait, c'est Pasco
euh Nyama, euh nous allons
battre les Gabonais, vive les
léopards, c'est Aaron euh
Zakozaki là qui qui nous écrit
euh mais peut-être que le le
prix Marc Vivien FOOT ça va
leur donner un supplément
d'âme. Sérieusement, vous
arrivez chancelle, meilleur
joueur américain de de Ligue
un. Ils n'ont pas perdu la
différence c'est que la
différence dans ce match, c'est
que le Gabon peut se contenter
des résultats nuls. Ils sont
leaders du groupe et avec un
nul, ils restent en tête, enfin
ils auront 8 points et et ils
vont en Mauritanie pour bon il
devrait se qualifier là à la
République démocratique du
Congo elle doit aller gagner et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au
match aller? C'est le Gabon qui
a gagné en RDC à se dire il y a
un gros problème euh du côté de
la RDC. Donc là là il y a quand
même une grosse pression sur
les léopards en plus Cédric
Bakambu est suspendu en
Mauritanie voilà, ça c'est pas
très bien passé euh, bon il
devrait titulariser du coup
fiston Mayelle qui est en
pleine bourre puisqu'il a
marqué 15 buts en Coupe de la
Confédération, il a amené euh,
les Tanzaniens du du yang
africain jusqu'en finale contre
l'USMA, ils ont failli gagner,
ça s'est joué à très peu de
choses parce qu'ils perdent à
euh à Dares-Salam, deux un,
mais autour euh à Alger, il
gagne un zéro et ils sont
vraiment pas loin de de marquer
ce deuxième but qui leur aurait
donné la victoire. Donc il y a
des, beaucoup de joueurs
congolais d'ailleurs dans cette
équipe tanzanienne, donc ils
sont en pleine forme,
maintenant est-ce que Dessabres
va réussir à créer l'amalgame?
C'est ça? Parce que
potentiellement, il y a bien
plus de bons joueurs euh en RDC
qu'au Gabon. RADIO un proverbe
africain pour les encourager et
les joueurs de la RDC je
pourrais bien dire par rapport
aux joueurs de la RDC c'est
juste que ils doivent encore
avoir confiance en eux parce
qu'ils sont des léopards et
comme le dit un proverbe
africain un léopard ne parle
pas à la chasse pour chercher
la tortue. Bon
Moi finalement on peut
peut-être euh euh en déco il y
aura d'autres matchs importants
bien sûr euh au cours du
week-end, vous le savez, vous
les suivrez grâce à RADIO
grâce au service des sports et
grâce à Mondial Sport et
notamment on en a parlé dans
Radio FOOT euh cette semaine eh
bien ce match important pour la
République Centrafricaine qui
jouera à Douala demain face à
l'Angola. On a aussi le Bénin
qui se retrouvera face au
Sénégal, ces deux matchs sont
samedi euh et puis on le le le
le le lui aussi il est dans une
Xavier sur tapis vert un un
match alors rajouter 3 points
et du coup tout est possible
euh la Côte d'Ivoire est déjà
enfin le qualifiée donc euh je
crois que quand même hein même
si c'est à domicile bon Pour
ceux qui aiment mais RADIO dans
les vieux pots on fait la bonne
soupe c'est pas ça? Oui.
Comment on dit euh? Qui s'en
rappelle la vieille mamie te
fait la bonne sauce. Voilà bon
hein. Il commence à s'y mettre,
attention RADIO
Euh et pour tous ceux qui
aiment euh un grand reportage
signé Martin Guez a été euh
diffusé euh aujourd'hui sur les
antennes, il le sera encore et
sinon vous avez toujours euh le
podcast qui est disponible.
Allez, on continue et on va
parler euh d'une compétition
c'est sa troisième édition, ça
s'appelle la ligue des nations.
Des nations. Et la Croatie
s'impose quatre buts à deux
face aux Pays-Bas. La Croatie
jouera la finale de cette
l'Espagne qualifiée pour la
finale de la ligue des nations.
Une compétition donc la ligue
des nations qui, peu à peu,
gagne ses adeptes, surtout
lorsqu'on arrive au tournoi
final, parce que là c'est
vraiment euh intéressant. On
avait euh donc eu des
demi-finales et pour la finale
on a une belle affiche, en tout
cas elle est prometteuse et
prometteuse de spectacles
puisque la Croatie jouera
contre l'Espagne pour donc le
trophée de cette troisième
édition aux Pays-Bas. Ça se
passe aux Pays-Bas, alors c'est
le Pays haute, c'est la nation
qui a été euh Xavier euh à
domicile alors que on on la
voyait déjà en et elle jouera
bien le match des perdants face
à l'Italie, mais Lucas Modric
et ses camarades sont euh sans
doute Frédéric euh Sutochet,
vous avez une tendresse pour la
la Croatie euh Luka Modric et
ses camarades parce quà chaque
fois on les voit arriver
jusqu'au dernier carré et puis
boum patatras euh ils y
arrivent pas. Non mais une
tendresse je sais pas mais je
les ai beaucoup commenté que ce
soit en Russie euh ou au Qatar
et c'est deux coupes du monde
là en 2018, ils arrivent en
finale ils étaient à bout de
souffle et puis ben en décembre
dernier ils nous ont fait une
superbe coupe du monde bis
repetita. Avec encore beaucoup
de
tirs au but mais c'est c'est la
marque de fabrique euh ouais.
Les les vieux briscards, les
Luka Modric euh moi je trouve
que c'est un peu du du
romanisme mais il la mériterait
cette Xavier-là là, ça fait 10
ans qu'il nous montre quand
même de très très belles
choses. Euh ça nous ferait
plaisir de les voir au bout de
la compétition avec le trophée.
Euh Xavier cette euh équipe.
Alors elles se sont retrouvées
euh à lors de l'euro ces deux
et ça avait été un match
absolument incroyable. Il y a
eu huit buts hein au total. Il
y avait eu encore des
prolongations et là c'était
l'Espagne qui avait gagné. Qui
voilà qui avait gagné cinq à
trois. Mais ces deux équipes
qui se connaissent en même
temps, l'équipe d'Espagne est
un peu en transition aussi on
voit. C'est c'est une nouvelle
Xavier par exemple José Lou là
qui les a qualifié mais on a
aussi Anne Sufati, Gavi, donc
euh un beau mélange. Il y a il
y a une nouvelle Xavier
espagnole clairement avec le
comme sélectionneur Louis
Delafouette qui a longtemps été
l'entraîneur des espoirs. Qui a
fait monter un peu certains
joueurs de cette Xavier en tout
cas il les a eu et il les
retrouve. Il les connaît bien.
Donc il y a il y a euh il y a
du talent dans cette équipe
d'Espagne euh il y a toujours
le même fond de jeu, il y a
aussi 2 joueurs français
naturalisés et Aymeric Laporte
et Robin Le Normand qui
composent la charnière centrale
et euh c'est-à-dire que leur
première mi-temps hier a été
Xavier
s'appelle la porte.
Tous les voleurs pouvant dire
comme il voulait. Heureusement
que Siro est immobilé, il n'a
aucune clé. Il a pas un trou.
Trois proverbes Xavier Non mais
c'est vrai que cette euh
nouvelle Xavier espagnole elle
est elle est intéressante pour
le jeu qu'elle développe parce
que on on les connaît et ils
arrivent à perpétuer ce ce ce
style qui est quand même euh
offensif et style hein offensif
parce que pour les avoir suivi
en plus à la coupe du monde moi
je trouvais que c'était un jeu
un peu euh stéréotypé parce que
ils avaient la possession de
balle, ils la maîtrisaient mais
derrière ils étaient pas
dangereux. Hier ils l'ont
toujours mais je trouve que ce
qui manque réellement à cette
équipe d'Espagne comparé à des
équipes passées euh c'est un
vrai attaquant, ils n'ont pas
d'attaquant. Hier on l'a encore
vu en oui mais ils sont
champions du monde sans Xavier
quand tu veux durer, tu veux
gagner des compétition un vrai
but. Ils ont grosse différence
entre l'Espagne d'avant et
celle de maintenant c'est que
l'Espagne d'avant elle était
constituée essentiellement de
joueurs du Barça qui se
trouvaient les yeux fermés et
de quelques joueurs du Real
Madrid de très haut niveau
comme Sergio Ramos. Ça. C'est
effectivement alors que
aujourd'hui vous avez plus
d'Espagnols qui jouent au RADIO
avec des étrangers, au Barça il
y a quelques jeunes et sinon
ils vont chercher des joueurs
qui sont dans des clubs de
deuxième niveau à Valence, à la
RADIO
de compétitivité Xavier de ces
joueurs espagnols, mais il y a
toujours ce collectif qui leur
permet d'atteindre des
objectifs élevés. RADIO
et bien évidemment ils ont
notre futur joueur José Lou qui
a quand même réussi à marquer
un but mais quand on voit le
nombre de buts que rate quand
même l'Espagne et surtout euh
le manque de justesse technique
de Murata, on est beaucoup
inquiet. Tu disais qu'ils ont
gagné la Coupe du monde sans un
bon sans un avant-centre. Mais
sauf que cet Espagne-là ne
prenait pas de but. Hein? Et
vous avez pu constater voilà.
C'est-à-dire que la coupe du
monde la coupe du monde et
d'ailleurs cette année ils
avaient pris un seul but. Et
c'était au premier match.
Contre la Suisse. Hum hum.
Après il n'y a pas de but. Mais
là équipe d'Espagne. Lorsque
vous regardez les couloirs,
mais c'est des attaquants qui
sont là-bas, c'est-à-dire que
les se retrouve latérale. De
l'autre côté, vous avez Alba
qui monte extrêmement, et la
charnière, ce n'est plus ce
qu'on avait avant, c'est de
dire un piquet et Ramos, qui
pouvait rattraper des coups. Et
du coup, quand je regarde cette
euh équipe-là, et même ce qu'on
nous présentait comme des
futurs euh grands joueurs, il
ne connaît même plus porter sa
tunique. Puisqu'il met
maintenant le nom devant et
puis il offre des Xavier perdu.
L'Italie c'est parce que
l'Italie aujourd'hui lorsque
vous jouez avec les Verratti,
les Gorgino qui n'ont plus ne
serait-ce qu'une seule calorie,
alors vous vous ne pouvez pas
gagner un match parce quà
partir de la soixantième
minute, eux tous ils sont
cuits. Et ils ne parvenaient
pas à faire trois passes. Mais
cinq équipes d'Espagne lorsque
elle se retrouve dans votre
camp et que vous avez un jeu
direct, je parle par exemple de
l'équipe de la Croatie ou au
milieu des terrains on peut
très bien cadenasser parce que
vous avez et qui d'ailleurs
encore a été élu homme du match
et devant vous pouvez avoir et
très très vite j'ai dit cette
équipe d'Espagne oui peut
compter est sur peut compter
sur la possession mais la
Croatie a une attaque
foudroyante et des gars qui
vont comme des flèches et comme
le dit justement un proverbe
africain tout bon chasseurs
fait son arc en fonction de
l'arbre. Euh, Benjamin est-ce
que pour vous il y a un un
favori dans dans cette euh,
dans cette finale? Bon alors on
sait hein, une finale mais
est-ce que pour vous justement
euh, écoutez RADIO même écoutez
Xavier et tout avec cette
fragilité quand même du côté de
RADIO vous pensez que la
Croatie est plus forte? Oui je
pense que la Croatie sur le
match mais je pense que la
Croatie est plus forte parce
que pour moi c'est l'équipe un
peu la mieux équilibrée en
terme défensive, même au milieu
et même en Xavier ils ont le
ballon, ils vont l'avoir ça
c'est sûr. La Croatie c'est au
final ils sont habitués, on
parlait depuis 208, ils sont
toujours là en décembre dernier
ils étaient là à la Coupe du
monde. Aujourd'hui ils sont là
et je trouve que malgré le fait
qu'ils arrivent toujours très
souvent, ils vont en
prolongation, on l'a vu encore
lors du dernier match, ils
passent ils tiennent, on dit
qu'ils sont vieux euh, Modric
en région de maudite mais
malgré son âge, il est encore
présent, mais les jeunes sont
là parce que il y a eu cette
transition-là qui est en train
de se faire et de et et et de
manière naturelle. Ça du Real
Madrid hein mélange entre les
vieux et les jeunes. Il faut
pas oublier que c'est un pays
qui a été en guerre et que ces
gamins-là ils sont nés avec
cette euh cet instinct de
survie. Et donc quand il y a
que trois Xavier doivent partir
pour des raisons économiques,
travailler en Allemagne, en
Suisse euh ou dans d'autres
pays européens. Euh c'est des
gamins qui sont nés avec la
guerre, qui ont grandi avec la
guerre, qui ont tous perdu un
oncle, une un cousin euh
quelqu'un de leur famille dans
dans ce cette guerre qui a
déchiré les Balkans au début
des années et donc quand il
joue pour le maillot de la
Croatie mais c'est pareil pour
les Serbes et les Bostiens
hein, ils jouent ils jouent
pour leur pour leur pays, pour
leur famille, ils ont vraiment
ce sentiment et quand vous
voyez ces jeunes qui arrivent,
il y en a beaucoup, on les
connaît pas, ils arrivent du
Dynamo de Zagreb, de l'Aïd de
Split, parfois ils jouent dans
des clubs de 2ième division
allemande, mais quand ils
arrivent sous le maillot euh
croate, ils sont transfigurés,
ils sont sur-motivés, parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils jouent
pour leur pays. Ils C'est une
Xavier ça. Exactement! C'est
une Xavier la guerre pour avoir
ce ce pour
ils ont cette Xavier
ils ont cette Xavier ils ont
quelques très bons joueurs pour
les guider effectivement
toujours là qui est
international depuis
deux-mille-huit hein premier
mars deux-mille-six Voilà et il
a joué l'Euro 200huit déjà donc
vous vous rendez compte. Donc
Modric est là, il y a
effectivement Brozovic euh euh
on en on en a parlé Vida en
défense c'est pas un grand mais
il lâche jamais rien. Donc ils
ont ils ont cet état d'esprit
qui fait que ils se surpassent
toujours. Les messages euh
Facebook euh alors archiduc lui
soutient l'Espagne, c'est une
bonne équipe en devenir, qui
fleurit euh bon ouais, Daouda
Die, la Croatie mais tu ne
donnes pas de fruits. La
Croatie mérite de gagner un
titre euh avec son milieu de
terrain fantastique, Modric
incroyable euh je suis à 100
pour % fan de l'Espagne, nous
dit Lama RADIO mais je voudrais
que la Croatie remporte le
trophée pour Lucas Moukand
qui remporte hein sur les cinq
euh l'Espagne a trois victoire,
la Croatie deux. On verra.
Suspense. Ouais. On verra ça.
En tout cas dimanche vous aurez
droit à deux finales on va
dire, il y a la finale des des
vainqueurs et la finale des
vainqueurs des nations. Waouh!
bon disons que c'est un match
donc on aura euh en finale le
soir la grande Xavier Croatie
-Espagne et l'après-midi il y
aura Pays-Bas euh Italie.
Pauvres Xavier pauvres Laurence
Eliminatoires
Français
Benjamin a écrit sur son compte
Twitter le club de Napoli. Eh
oui, Rudi Garcia le romain hein
euh est au rebond et il
rebondit du côté de Naples avec
le Napoli. Il est désormais
donc rudit le napolitain. Alors
lui qui avait laissé
d'excellents souvenirs en en
Série A, vous vous en souvenez,
il avait passé hum deux ans
voilà, deux ans et demi, pas
tout à fait trois saisons euh
du côté de la Roma. Il a été
choisi par le club Champions
d'Italie pour euh Xavier le
banc, le Napoli euh l'a nommé
hier soir comme successeur de
Luciano Spalletti est amusant
c'est quand il avait quitté la
Roma, ses spaletiques qui
avaient succédé euh à RADIO à
59 ans, l'ancien champion de
France, on s'en souvient avec
Lille hein notamment euh prend
du grade, est-ce que c'est pour
vous parce que c'est il il
atterrit quand même dans le
club champion d'Italie, est-ce
que pour vous c'est un choix
euh audacieux euh Xavier Barret
du président de Lorenzis? Du
non je pense c'est un choix
assez raisonné finalement parce
que il a fait un peu le tour
des entraîneurs Xavier ces
dernières années, il en euh des
des des très bons euh ça a très
bien fonctionné, Ancelotti, ça
n'a pas marché, euh RADIO pas
très bien, et Spalletti voulait
pas rester. Donc euh plutôt que
de d'aller prendre un
entraîneur Xavier qui aurait
forcément difficilement soutenu
la comparaison, même si on a
beaucoup parlé de Vince Enzo
Italiano, l'actuel entraîneur
de la FOOT finale de la coupe
de la de la Ligue Europa
Conférence. Euh il a préféré
Rudi Garcia , moi je trouve que
c'est pas un mauvais choix,
Rudi Garcia par l'Italien. Et
il a déjà cette expérience,
vous l'avez rappelé, Annie,
deux ans et demi Romain avec
deux deuxièmes places derrière
la Juventus qui était à
l'époque intouchable. Et donc
Ligue des Champions. Donc donc
euh donc voilà une une vraie
expérience avec des bons
résultats en Italie. Après la
troisième année a été la
troisième saison a été un peu
plus compliquée, elle est
partie en cours de saison. Mais
euh Rudi Garcia il a
l'expérience euh d'avoir
entraîné des grands clubs,
d'avoir été champion de France
en Italie, en France, pardon,
d'avoir été deux fois deuxième
en Italie, je pense que c'est
un choix intéressant. Euh
Benjamin le défi c'est quand
même euh le club champion euh
d'Italie, on sait qu'ils ont
attendu pendant 33 ans ce titre
et et le et le défi
pratiquement c'est eh bien de
de avec ce club de rester euh
champion d'Italie. Alors je
sais pas si c'est euh
l'objectif qu'on lui fixe bien
sûr mais en tout cas euh de pas
être euh Xavier et ça c'est un
vrai défi pour une équipe on se
souvient notamment de de nos
amis de So FOOT qui en avaient
fait une une à un moment où on
se dit euh euh le Napoli avait
un jeu tellement joli et
tellement léché, est-ce que
Rudi Garcia correspond à ça?
Mais c'est ça justement je
pense que c'est il va il risque
d'avoir un gros problème parce
que je j'attends de voir, je
suis impatient de voir ce qu'il
va mettre en place où il dit
parce que reste le même. Oui,
faut pas avoir le même Xavier
mais après ce que vous demandez
aux joueurs c'est comportement
différent, ce qui est demandé
Spalletti à ses joueurs ça peut
être complètement différent de
de ce que Rudi Garcia fera
parce que automatiquement quand
il arrive il va vouloir
imprégner de sa part dans
l'équipe, il va pas uniquement
être dans la continuité de de
ce qu'il s'est déjà fait. Ben
moi je trouve que où je me je
me pose la question euh euh
Frédéric c'est Frédéric c'est
que moi pour moi je trouve que
Rudi Garcia ça correspond ça
corres pas forcément à à à
l'identité de Naples. Parce que
pour moi Naples c'est un club,
oui vous allez me dire qu'il
est entraîné à Marseille, parce
que c'est une ville un peu
chaude, c'est à peu près le
même repas de la oui mais moi
je trouve que Naples c'est une
histoire un peu plus forte et
même la ville qui vit un peu
plus que Marseille. Pour être
allé là-bas regarder des
matchs, oui. Et est-ce que Rudi
Garcia de par son management
correspond, moi je trouve que
Spalletti il a bien géré parce
que c'était un entraîneur il
fallait montrer au créneau, il
y allait. Il allait pas de main
morte. Il allait pas avec le
dos de la cuillère. Garcia il a
fait ça la Roma quand il s'est
embrouillé avec euh Toty
justement parce que Toty il
avançait plus euh ça ça a été
compliqué pour lui à à gérer
euh donc il sait il sait gérer
des situations délicates dans
des grands clubs Xavier hein.
En face de lui il a quand même
un président euh on on sait
quand même comment ben le
comment il est hein c'est
difficile de de de le gérer
mais effectivement il va avoir
la pression parce que quand
vous êtes champion vous arrivez
dans un club qui a gagné et qui
est arrivé en en en quart de
demi-finale je crois de de
champions en en League de il
arrive en demi-finale
Là c'est autre chose là quoi.
Là c'est un autre but. RADIO ce
que vous dites, il y a beaucoup
d'auditeurs qui nous parlent
d'un triplé de Pegg Guardiola
hein mais je pourrais de hein.
Comment on peut faire un truc
là à à un milliard? Moi
RADIO RADIO il avait laissé
aussi un bon souvenir à Rome
justement parce que il avait un
un jeu très offensif avec les
Garcia et et il avait laissé un
bon souvenir aussi, je pense
que peut-être je sais pas, il
sait s'adapter avec l'effectif.
J'ai l'impression que vous
lisez la lettre à l'envers
parce que s'il avait laissé un
bon souvenir, il n'aurait pas
été limogé. Au moment où il est
limogé, il faut justement dire
que le président de l'AS Rome a
dit c'est-à-dire que après son
limangeage que j'aurais dû en
début de saison, parce que même
la saison d'avant mais RADIO
quand tu fais le deuxième juste
une chose, il il a un record de
hum euh de victoire consécutive
c'est dix hein avec la Roma ça
quand euh regarde on regarde
les trophées. C'est-à-dire que
si aujourd'hui on parle de Rudi
Garcia qui a commencé au Xavier
qui se retrouve bientôt à 60
ans, donc bientôt à la
retraite, mais on lui dit non,
le gars en fait il a gagné bon
on on croirait que il a juste
remporté un match de l'île de
la tentation. Après cela il
s'est grillé un peu partout.
Parce que justement quand vous
le regardez avec l'effectif de
l'AS Roma, bien évidemment le
président a souligné une chose,
c'est que en Italie on parle
tactique et stratégie et il a
dit que Rudi Garcia ne
parvenait pas à parler
stratégie. La preuve, quand il
est limogais, ils sont sur 11
matchs sans une seule victoire.
Hum hum. Et ils font seulement
trois matchs nuls et par la
suite il n'allait pas se
qualifier en Ligue des
champions. Lorsqu'il est
licencié, c'est là où reprend
de l'envol et justement l'AS
Roma est qualifiée en Ligue des
champions. Je peux par exemple
le garder ce qu'il a fait en
Arabie Saoudite. On a vu
peut-être que
à Marseille jusqu'à ce que
Cristiano Ronaldo arrive, il
est en tête du championnat
d'Arabie Saoudite, il est
leader et puis tout d'un coup
Cristiano Ronaldo arrive et là
ça dégringole, ils perdent.
Mais si, on lui a mais il avait
trouvé, il avait une équipe qui
avait un équilibre, ils étaient
leaders du championnat,
Cristiano Ronaldo arrive, ça a
**** tout par terre, ils se
font, ils se sont fait éliminer
de la ligue, ils sont ils ont
tout perdu. Si ils ont été
virés, ils
un attaquant lui a remporté
avec tous les autres pays. Et
maintenant un entraîneur n'a
remporté qu'avec la France
après avoir fait le tour du
monde. Rudi Garcia et il y a
donc un proverbe africain qui
dit j'attendais la souris a
beau faire l'hôtel, le
pèlerinage à travers le monde
elle n'attrapera jamais le
chat. Ouais. Nos auditeurs. Les
auditeurs, téléspectateurs, ils
sont plutôt dubitatifs hein
également euh, Garcia Napoli
est trop grand pour toi euh
nous dit euh euh Eugène euh
mais avant l'émission à Nice
c'est vrai qu'on on se disait
en tout cas il sait très bien
se vendre Rudi Garcia hein euh
quand il est arrivé à Lyon on
pensait que ça allait être
Laurent Bian et puis euh
Jean-Michel Aulas le président
euh bien avait reconnu et que
il a passé dix jours à discuter
avec le président quel Xavier
consultant à la télévision donc
euh c'est un bon commun allez
Rudi Garcia eh bien on
observera ce qu'il fera avec le
Napoli et on fera ça avec
gourmandise Sergent Garcia hein
ils l'ont surnommée comme ça
pendant un moment euh du côté
de Rome on continue on va
parler du du chouchou euh des
des joueurs euh de football
français.
Bonjour Kylian, est-ce que vous
avez quitté le Paris
Saint-Germain et la Ligue 1euh
l'été prochain? RADIO c'est
c'est ma seule euh ma seule
option pour le moment donc euh
Kylian
Mbappé le capitaine des
Bleus est au coeur du jeu bien
sûr euh et des attentions grâce
à lui le feuilleton est
permanent se dit-on à Radio
FOOT International, merci
Kylian parce que du coup on a
toujours plein de grains à
moudre ces performances
sportives évidemment sont
incontestables et parfois euh
même euh fascinantes mais elles
l'ont conduit à déborder
peut-être en dehors de de de
son bon vouloir euh des
terrains et des pelouses, il
devient un personnage au
quotidien. Alors le numéro 10
des Bleus, vous le savez euh
est à l'origine des vagues
qu'il suscite. Cette semaine,
il y a eu la fameuse lettre
envoyée aux dirigeants du Paris
Saint-Germain et du coup il y a
eu plein de débats, plein de
choses euh dites autour de lui
ce qu'il y a, c'est qu'il est
en équipe de France ces
jours-ci. Alors du coup ça part
à, bon alors c'est vrai que
l'affiche euh France Gibraltar
est pas euh des plus
passionnantes, ce qui fait
qu'on peut parler d'autre
chose. Il y avait eu le pivot
Gang à un certain moment, il y
avait eu aussi la contestation
des contrats avec les sponsors.
Bref, euh Kylian Mbappé hier
euh était euh assez euh il
était euh euh il est venu
devant la presse mais il était
un petit peu contrarié, agacé.
Alors est-ce que euh Mbappé est
agacé ou agaçant? On se
demandait tout à l'heure euh
Rémi, surtout est-ce qu'il en
fait trop notre champion du
monde pour vous? Je trouve que
Kylian Mbappé aide l'exemple de
la jeunesse actuelle. Ce ne
sont pas qui étions soumis à
nos papas au monde entier. Ne
pouvant jamais parler étant
toujours là, même pour porter
des K de société. Kylian Mbappé
le fait avec une certaine
aisance parce qu'il a une bonne
personnalité, une forte
personnalité. Non seulement il
est bon au niveau des jambes
mais il est aussi bon au niveau
de la tête. Et de telle sorte
que Xavier remarque il n'est
pas le wagon. C'est une
locomotive. Et la locomotive
tire les autres vers le haut.
Ceux qui disent que Kylian
Mbappé est en train d'en faire
trop. Ils n'ont quà prendre
donc les footballeurs de
l'ancien testament qui était
déjà habitué à des
comportements attendant
toujours que leurs parents
puissent décider à leur place.
Kylian Mbappé va de l'avant et
de toutes les façons tu as le
talent. Quelle mais alors quel
défaut? Oui ou David Finsel?
Dans le football français vous
avez toujours eu des fortes
personnalités. Alors après le
contexte a un peu évolué
surtout mais Michel Platini
Michel Platini on était
toujours à à ses flûtes à
savoir ce qui se passait,
comment il allait, il avait une
petite blessure, il avait euh
envie de de d'ailleurs et
cetera et même Zidane avec sa
nature très effacée, il faisait
aussi la une des des gazettes à
chaque fois. À chaque fois et
comme Zidane n'avait pas cette
facilité d'élocution de Kylian
Mbappé on l'entendait beaucoup
moins. Kylian Mbappé il sait
très bien s'exprimer, il sait
ce qu'il veut, il a le talent
pour. Après euh qu'est-ce qu'on
peut lui reprocher là dans
cette affaire de du de la
lettre au PSG il a un droit, il
a euh quelque chose à faire de
de son contrat euh il veut pas
prolonger jusqu'en 2025 et le
signal dès le mois de juin
alors qu'il pouvait attendre le
31 juillet. Ça lui retombe
dessus, je trouve ça un peu
bizarre parce qu'il a justement
au club euh la possibilité de
recruter quelqu'un d'autre.
S'organiser. De s'organiser
avec un euh semaine ou six
semaines devant lui plutôt que
de leur signaler ça le 30
juillet et qu'ils aient plus
que
Pour une fois on est d'accord.
Ouais et puis alors en plus il
y a quelques ondes
camerounaises euh autour de de
Kylian Mbappé alors je pense
que ça retombe sur ce studio
mais euh Benjamin Xavier dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher? En fait ce qu'on se
dit c'est mince on parle
beaucoup du coup de la lettre
de Kylian euh tout ça mais il y
a toute une équipe de France
quand même, il y a 22 personnes
autour et là ces jours-ci alors
on en parlera sûrement les
prochaines heures avec les deux
matchs que dispute l'équipe de
France mais on a l'impression
qu'il vole un peu la vedette.
Oui mais non c'est parce que
c'est les journalistes qui vont
lui poser la question
concernant son avenir. C'est un
jeu de c'est-à-dire que il y en
a un qui alimente l'autre je si
quelque part parce que à la
conférence de Xavier pourquoi
pas aller lui parler du match?
Il y a un match ce soir mais
vous lui parlez du match et
c'est ce qu'il a dit à un
moment donné. Après moi je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'il a dit
Xavier et RADIO ce qu'ils ont
dit c'est exactement ça. Vous
voulez lui reprocher quoi? Il y
a rien à lui reprocher? Et en
plus moi je me je me rappelle
la saison dernière quand il
décide de prolonger il le dit
je voulais pas partir du PSG
sans que le PSG ne puisse
prendre de l'argent. C'est pour
ça que j'ai décidé de oui parce
qu'il voulait pas partir
gratuitement. Hum hum. Et pour
moi je pense que cette
sortie-là qu'il faut
aujourd'hui pour leur dire,
écoutez là je vais pas
prolonger, je vais pas euh
actionner euh cette option que
j'ai avec vous, ben vous avez
la possibilité de me vendre,
ben vendez-moi cette année, je
pense honnêtement qu'il veut
partir quand même. Pas de
redire depuis trois jours et je
veux être là l'année prochaine
ça ça c'est les joueurs moi
j'ai j'ai été un joueur, j'ai
j'ai j'ai j'ai ça à peu près
comment ça se ou euh faut pas
être naïf non plus
Il envoie la lettre parce que
Kylian Mbappé il envoie la
lettre justement parce que je
pense qu'il veut partir. Et
puis ben vu que le ne va pas
Xavier ne pas le vendre ou le
le laisser je suis pas sûr
qu'ils vont le laisser jusqu'à
la jusqu'à l'année bah cette
année ben pour moi il faut il
faut il faut le transférer.
Frédéric est-ce que ça
passionne nos euh nos auditeurs
internautes? Panthères avec lui
hein euh Olivier si le PSG veut
se faire respecter, il doit le
vendre euh Tarcy Salin, Mbappé
est en train de plomber
lui-même sa carrière. Bon je
les ai peut-être un peu
choisies euh mais Xavier
Xavier que voilà on on te
propose encore de l'argent
alors que le gars voulait
partir au Real à une certaine
période, aujourd'hui il dit que
bon, prenez de l'argent et vous
vous taisez c'est tout ce qu'il
est en train de demander au PSG
de m'accuser pas plus tard
parce qu'il y a un proverbe
africain qui dit le chien qui
annonce dans sa bouche n'aboie
plus. Alors euh il n'aboie plus
et nous euh on va euh
s'intéresser aux cartons du
jour et à ceux de nos auditeurs
bien sûr. Carton jaune! Un
carton jaune oh là là là là!
Carton rouge! Carton rouge!
Dans la conclusion. Carton
vert!
On a reçu tellement de cartons
et de bons cartons cette
semaine que David Findel n'a
pas réussi à à en Xavier assez
donc euh ça sera vous allez
voir une très belle séquence.
Bonjour Radio FOOT
sous un bel arbre vert à Bangui
en République centrafricaine.
Mon carton est vert, adressé au
four de Bazoubangui. Je leur
souhaite toute la reçu de la
chance que Dieu soit avec nous,
pour une première qualification
à la CAN salut à vous. Merci.
Bonjour Radio FOOT c'est
Emmanuel depuis Port-Gentil au
Gabon. Alors, mon carton de la
semaine sera un carton vert
pour Silvio Berlusconi. Il
mérite ce carton durant ces 30
années à la tête de il a su
rapporter 5 titres de Ligue des
champions et on sait que les
grands joueurs comme Chelloti,
An et autres sont passés sous
sa direction. Il a vraiment
fait de 1000 ans ce que 1000
ans est devenu. On voit
vraiment qu'il est totalement
l'opposé des dirigeants
d'aujourd'hui comme ceux de
Paris. Mais bon merci bonne
Xavier à vous. Salut salut café
des sports c'est depuis le sud
du Togo. Mon carton il est
rouge et il va aux dirigeants
parisiens. Pourquoi? Pourquoi
Kylian Mbappé de prolonger son
contrat avec le PSG. C'est le
moment ou jamais de le laisser
partir et reconstruire une
équipe plus compétitive, plus
collective et être patient. Ce
n'est pas en changeant toutes
les années les entraîneurs
qu'on peut y arriver. Ciao
ciao. Radio FOOT international,
bonjour. Depuis le Burkina
Faso. Aujourd'hui mon carton il
est de couleur rouge à
l'endroit de tout ce qui n'est
pas si bon que ça. Il ne
bénéficie que des meilleurs
joueurs. À commencer par RADIO
. Je vous rappelle qu'une chose
est d'avoir les très bons
joueurs dans son équipe, une
autre et de savoir les faire
jouer ensemble et le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes. Carton rouge à
vous et bonne émission. Salut
Radio FOOT National. Ici c'est
les Français nouveaux. Nous
ados Bienvenue du Bénin qui est
en train de rajeunir l'équipe
pour laisser les feux, les
vieux, les vieux Xavier à la
maison pour pendant les qui
part qui peuvent courir sur le
terrain et représenter notre
pays. Comme le dit un problème
africain. Un le gibier à un
chasseur. Ciao ciao. Bonjour
internationale, c'est Boubacar
Diallo depuis qui donne pour ce
café de sport un carton très
très riche à mon pays la Guinée
parce que depuis 64 ans
maintenant nous avons notre
indépendance et nous n'avons
pas un seul stade qui répond
aux normes internationales donc
on ne peut pas accueillir nos
matchs ici à Conakry et là on a
joué face à l'Egypte et on a
perdu ça va nous coûter cher
parce que c'est pas encore sûr
qu'on se qualifie pour la
prochaine CAN c'est nos voisins
Xavier le football avant nous
sommes les infrastructures donc
carte à la Guinée parce qu'il y
a un proverbe africain qui dit
on ne peut pas aller aux Xavier
sans la roue. Merci, bon Café
des sports à vous et bon
week-end, ciao. Salut Radio
FOOT c'est depuis le Sénégal.
Eh bien, pour cette émission je
voudrais attribuer un carton
vert à reprendre peut-être
comparé à notre Laurent Salerno
qui fait briller les autres
sans pour autant être devant le
feu des projets de un travail
de l'ombre, rugby, meilleur
joueur de la Champions League
Rodrigue, meilleur joueur de la
demi-finale de la Nation et
peut-être un trophée de la
le plus grand club au monde.
Eux on t'attend avec plaisir,
bois ouvert. Moi c'est je suis
à Kinshasa. Je donne un carton
vert à Mbappé je ne veux pas
qu'il quitte Paris. Merci
beaucoup, bisous. Seigneur ce
matin c'est depuis Kinshasa en
République Démocratique du
Congo. Je donne un carton très
très vert à Lyonnais d'avoir
marqué un joli contre l'équipe
australien. Un match amical.
Merci, je vous aime beaucoup.
Salut à Xavier Marie. Salut
Radio FOOT International. Ici
c'est et Nathanaël
d'Île-de-France, notre carton
est vert pour les droits télé
acceptés par TF1 et M6 pour
diffuser la Coupe du monde
féminine euh, du football.
Merci Annie Gasnier de nous
représenter dans ce monde
masculin. On vous adore. Merci
beaucoup Alfie et oui on aura
tous le plaisir en France de
suivre ce football euh, féminin
qui sera euh, diffusé par M6 et
le service public de France
télé. Euh, merci aussi et à
toutes les filles hein qui se
mobilisent euh, on adore ça.
Allez, on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps, alors je vais vous
demander d'être bref, mais je
vais prendre la main. Juste,
juste pour euh, parce que c'est
dans le droit fil euh, un
carton vert euh, vert euh,
jaune euh, jaune et noir aux
filles de la sec, mimosa. Qui
euh, sont championnes euh, de
Côte d'Ivoire après les
garçons. Hors les filles,
c'était la première fois,
c'était leur première saison,
c'était la première fois
qu'elle euh, menait une saison
euh, une équipe féminine. Donc
on veut les saluer et on leur
dit bravo bravo à Paul euh
Martinez euh à Fatim grâce
Leslie ou encore à Francine et
Viviane Marie. Bravo les
filles, continuez. Euh à vous
euh pour ce qui est du du
carton RADIO RADIO à la
présidente du comité de
normalisation du Tchad euh elle
s'appelle Jacqueline Moudena
qui était jugé comme euh une
femme qui venait moderniser et
relancer le football tchadien
mais curieusement on constate
ce comité non seulement a
échoué pour sa première a
encore prolongé mais on se rend
quand même compte que le Tchad
ne parvient même pas à Xavier
ce comité de normalisation même
en match amical comme la
Somalie un pays en guerre
pavillon frère et mais par la
suite on veut tout simplement
que le Tchad puisse gagner il y
a un problème africain qui dit
ne demandez pas aux chameau de
porter vos charges alors qu'il
a soif. Euh la couleur de votre
carton Benjamin Vert, vert et
c'est pour Simonine Zaki
l'entraîneur de l'Inter pour ce
parcours euh magnifique,
exceptionnel d'ailleurs qu'ils
ont fait en en Champions
League, ils auraient même pu
gagner, moi j'y ai cru et euh,
juste pour rappeler à RADIO ce
match-là euh, l'Inter a été la
seule équipe en Champions
League à avoir eu plus
d'occasions que Manchester
City, voilà. Ah oui. Mais RADIO
il était pour l'Inter hein, je
vous rassure euh. RADIO si si
vraiment. Grâce grâce au
gardien. RADIO jaune euh au au
violet du Toulouse Football
Club qui euh remporte la Coupe
euh de France. Ça fait plus de
50 ans qu'ils l'attendaient,
qui vont être en Coupe d'Europe
la saison prochaine, ça fait 20
ans qu'on les y a pas vu et qui
virent leur entraîneur Philippe
Montanier après avoir non
prolongé 4 joueurs importants
dont les trois milieux de
terrain belges néerlandais qui
les ont fait reventer. Où
est-ce qu'on va? Parce que que
Toulouse soit pas une ville de
foot, on le sait, c'est plutôt
une ville de rugby, mais
surtout ils ont quand même
représenté la France en Coupe
d'Europe et on va encore avoir
une équipe. Je pense que. Non
compétition. L'intelligence
artificielle aurait réponse à
vous donner. Moi il est jaune,
carton jaune euh mais c'est en
écho à certains des cartons
qu'on a vus. Pour Lionel Messi
parce que il est dur quand même
avec les supporters parisiens
notamment euh il a quitté Paris
en disant ben j'ai passé deux
années où j'étais pas très
heureux à Paris. Puis là il est
à Pékin, il fait encore un
super match euh contre
l'Australie, donc quand il veut
le Lionel Messi, c'est encore
un joueur exceptionnel. Et nous
malheureusement, on aurait bien
voulu continuer, mais c'est la
fin de ce Café des Sports.
Merci à tous, bon week-end.